(upbeat orchestral music)
- You thought you knew crêpes,
but you were wrong.
Clickbait-y opening
line, and cue title card.
(gentle string music)
This whole story requires
you to know one basic fact:
This is not a crêpe.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] It may look, smell,
and taste like what you
might call a crêpe, but...
(speaking in foreign language)
(dinging)
- [Narrator] This
distinction is a big deal.
And you should listen to Jean Paul
because Jean Paul is the
current Grand Commando
of the Brotherhood of the Galette,
whose headquarters are
here in Pipriac, France,
a city in the northern region of Brittany,
or Breton as they say here.
This group, comprised of 25
members, has one purpose:
to keep the tradition of
the Breton galette alive,
and to protect the original
recipe and its ingredients.
So let's start at the beginning.
What is a galette?
(pleasant orchestral music)
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] So what's the
best way to serve a galette?
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Clearly, you're
wondering about the costumes.
Don't worry, we asked.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] All of this is to say
with tradition comes a
sort of responsibility.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Plus, this seems like
a fun group to be a part of, right?
(electronic dinging)